[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
boston i'm headed your way march 31st to
april 2nd get your tickets at
ryansickler.com let's get this tea party
started
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pass
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media uh look i just want to say thank
you i say it every week and i mean it
every time i say it thank you for the
messages thank you for the love
um you're changing my life too all right
you want to change it even more hit that
subscribe on the youtube y'all you know
what i'm saying it's a free way to help
the podcast all right
um if you gotta have more honeydew then
you gotta check out the patreon it's
every thursday
you're getting a honeydew a day early ad
free at no additional cost it's five
bucks if you're in for the long haul
sign up for a year you're getting over a
month free all right the stories are
wild we're not going anywhere anytime
soon the honeydew with y'all y'all all
right now
um get your tickets for all my tour
dates at ryansickler.com so you know we
do over here we highlight the lowlights
i always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers i'm very excited
to have this guest first time here on
the honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome christina hutchinson welcome to
the honeydew hello thank you thank you
thank you for being here as well i know
you've been patiently waiting out there
but i've been patiently waiting because
i'm telling you i've been a fan for a
long time i've been watching what you
guys do not only as
as comedians but as as business women
out there and you guys [ __ ] made some
real goddamn moves so congrats to you
yeah i appreciate that um please before
we get into what we're going to get into
um
uh will you plug promote everything yeah
absolutely our special day is the debut
stand-up comedy special of myself and
corinne fisher we self-produced it
corinne directed it and is available to
watch for free on youtube.com guys we
[ __ ] without the you in [ __ ] um
which is also our social media handles i
got i'm at christina hutch on all
platforms and um yeah should i do tour
dates or yeah
i'm gonna be may 12th in uh london uh
may 13th in dublin and uh oh april 9th
that's out of order but i'll be in miami
for a bitcoin conference really and i
get paid partially in bitcoin
i haven't dived in yet it's it's all
right i i i did early and then i pulled
out because i made ten thousand dollars
and i was like i'm a millionaire um but
if i would have kept that in for three
more years i would have been 100
millionaire
so you know you live in you alarm
so just my thing is like you could
collect all that but if you don't have
somebody to buy it you don't get the
money right uh i don't think it when you
sell it it's like a stock so you sell it
whenever you want it just depends on the
price but somebody's got to buy it
i don't think so they give you cash
right i don't think so no i've sold
because when i sold it you didn't get
cash instantly it went to my bank
the money but u.s dollars yeah right
okay that's what i mean i i'm sorry i'm
saying cash i mean american us dollars
oh yeah so someone's gotta trade you u.s
dollars for your bitcoin obviously to
cash it out yeah and it's a mystery who
that is right and i guess the government
everybody's waiting for the government
to go you have 100 million we think
that's worth three dollars right yeah
that's right but when he transfers to
your chase account but if you can get it
that's what i'm saying if you get it now
get it yeah
um okay so i'm very excited to have you
sit here because your email came in too
and you have
something that's been going on uh we've
had a few um
conversations lately about suicide and
things like that
um which is always it's always yeah
unfortunately and
um
you had said your mom but before we get
to that just tell me a little bit about
your background like where are you from
where'd you grow up yeah so i spent a
lot of my childhood in um chesapeake
virginia because my dad was in the navy
and uh from age two to ten
mom was very mentally ill
uh no one talked about it she would do
i have an older brother who eight years
older than me very i who i'm very very
close with thank god i have him i feel
like i'm we're war buddies um
i've been in the trenches of my my home
uh it's very important that i have
somebody else who's experienced this um
it was
one of those things where when you grow
up in the environment you grow up and
you think that's what everybody has like
you don't you don't know that it's
different but you're like i'm pretty
sure this sucks
uh but i was very imaginative and very
um
i would just get lost in my imagination
so i spent a lot of time alone playing
uh but yeah mom was very mentally ill
there was one period where she lived in
a car
um mary to your dad
yeah uh we had a house built in virginia
and uh then we moved into it and then um
there was yeah it was very confusing so
we lived in there for a couple years
into living there i was maybe four uh
she lived in a car and i was like
where's
where from outside or like by the way i
think she drove to the beach she drove
to another location
and she's a house we had a giant house a
beautiful i just i remember like as a
kid i appreciated how beautiful our
house was i really did
and uh
she would
my brother told me this recently she
would
sneak into the house
we one time we were out to eat we would
always go to old country buffet uh it
was me my brother my dad and we were
coming back and we were pulling into the
garage and my mom was in the garage and
i i was in like a car seat in the back
so i was like i couldn't tell but my i
heard my brother like mom she went into
the garage to steal my brother's roller
blades so she could sell them at a flea
market and buy him a birthday present
[Music]
because a couple days later there was
like a like a phone she brought him like
a landline phone like one of the
see-through ones with all the colored
things and he's like i wanted those
well
so that [ __ ] would happen uh but what do
you like okay well that's obvious
there's something wrong there yeah but
i'm a little kid so i'm like ooh mom's
back oh mom's going dad's not talking
much about it with you guys
your little don't you wish they would
have treated us more like adults then
because even though it [ __ ] us up at
least make more sense in the end when we
go to work on it right because because
what a kid does i've learned i've i've
read this book called the body keeps the
score that changed me
um basically about how trauma lives in
your body and so uh the author talks
about ptsd and veterans but uh it also
is similar in kids who experience
adverse childhood experiences which is
what they're called technically and
there's like a long list of them and you
can [ __ ] your kid up
very easily i mean you could you could
look at them weird and it [ __ ] them up
like it's not not just one time but you
know consistently looking at them
without a smile without a happy face
will [ __ ] up a kid psyche um and so
so yeah no one talked about it she
hallucinated a lot on medications
because the doctors put her on a lot of
medications they weren't listening to
her when she said that they weren't
working and they were making her things
worse they're like yeah just give it a
couple more
uh you know months and yeah she was
always
um
par like her emotions were always
paramount like we kind of bowed down and
looked to her like
can we do this is this okay like should
we go out to eat his mom okay well if
mom's okay we'll just stay home and eat
you know peanut butter and butter
sandwiches that way i ate that a lot
healthy diet peanut butter and butter
i've never had that yeah country crock
butter jelly oh i had the country crock
spread for sure oh yeah and then you
recycle that tub oh you don't you don't
throw that double don't you keep that
tub for leftovers yep
yep
or a sandbox make sand castle
so what kind of what memories of your
mom do you have that were positive like
was she was she was she she wanted to be
a good mom she okay so she was she
wanted crazy but she wasn't a bad person
well it's no no she's not a bad person
for sure but uh it's it's so many layers
oh so many layers uh she
wanted to
like she dressed me up a lot she always
wanted a little girl
and my brother and i were eight years
apart she had a lot of miscarriages um
before she had me and there was one
instance she she told me this where uh
she had to get rushed to the hospital
when she was about seven months pregnant
and there was there had been a giant
tumor in the womb with me
they got on the scan about four months
into her pregnancy with me and so they
were monitoring it and then about seven
months in they had to rush her to the
hospital because she was bleeding and
while you're in her belly yeah holy [ __ ]
and they took a scan and everything was
fine and the tumor was gone so i'm like
i probably ate it
because i i what happens is when you're
a parent with depression
you and i'm a sensitive kid i think i
think i would have been born sensitive
either way
you
you only focus on their needs because
and it's something i've learned in
therapy my therapist is a trauma
specialist she said when when a a
child's nervous system cannot handle the
fact that a parent can't take care of
them or a parent doesn't want to take
care of them and so because a child will
die there's a lot there's been a lot of
studies on this there's a famous world
war ii study where in orphanages um all
the babies that got food clothing diaper
changes but not all of them were held by
nurses because there wasn't enough staff
the babies that weren't held died even
though they got you everything you
needed to care they need to touch
so
that's how sensitive we are skin on skin
i remember skin on skin on skin but they
all there's also another really
important thing where for the child's
emotional health
the child needs to experience their
parent
being
joyful just because the kid is happy
like it uh she worded it much better
than this but like basically the child
needs to experience their their parent
really just loving them
just because they exist like that's it i
i say it all the time like your [ __ ]
[ __ ] trip to europe and i want to go
here and turks and ken none of that
[ __ ] matters all that matters is that
you love hard you show up and at least
at least act like you're genuinely
interested in what the [ __ ] they're
doing that's all you gotta
yeah yeah
uh and so
the my childhood was very well i didn't
know what mom i was gonna get because
the medications [ __ ] her up that's it
[ __ ] around you're always wondering
who's coming who's coming down the
stairs right
so i like
my therapist said she's she put it in a
way that i was like that's very that
feels very like a good metaphor she's
like both your antennas were pointed
towards your mom not one was pointed
towards you like usually a kid a kid has
an ego especially a baby they they're
they think that the only person that
exists and then whoever's in front of
them right so um so that's that's you
know until they grow out of that phase
they need to be like really nurtured and
loved um and i was certainly my mom
wanted kids so bad and so and she wanted
a girl and i was you know eight years
after my brother and there was a lot of
um a lot of health scares when i was
born so i think i was born into this um
she's so fearful of my mom
that something bad is going to happen to
all of us and so i think with me it was
just
like she didn't want i was just this
precious thing that she wanted to keep
in an incubator and not like learn from
my own mistakes as i grow older like
that's the form it would take as i grow
older um and so
yeah it was it was
i didn't know it was weird
but uh but not as an adult
when i say abusive physical or uh yeah i
got hit a lot by her
she would take her anger out of me
really uh she would brush my hair when
she was uh and i would cry because i
have really thick curly hair she didn't
and she has curly hair too but she
didn't really know how to brush it and
so she would just kind of yank it when
she was in a bad mood and i would cry
and i would say stop and she would get
mad at me for crying and i'm like this
is
so it was a lot of that so uh i grew up
kinda
i don't know just not knowing who i was
this is what i need to do with ryan
zigler
[Laughter]
i even turned the camera for it i
appreciate it
i genuinely appreciate it you're welcome
i'll probably do that a couple more
times you'll get you'll get a lot of
variations
we should get honey do tissues i should
just get a
cup
and then i'll drink it after
okay so you grow up not knowing not only
who you are but who who mom's gonna be
day-to-day yeah and my dad was just
that's a lot of anxiety a lot of anxiety
for an adult being a child so now you're
also having a parent as a kid and get
this oh god
i spent so my dad retired from the navy
when i was about five
he got drafted
he retired as a chief very he excelled
in the navy and um
when he retired he did all these weird
jobs and i was so i was a kid so i
didn't know i was like this feels [ __ ]
up but i didn't have the vernacular to
say anything because i didn't know how
to you know really relate to people yet
but my dad cleaned parking lots
uh
with like a street sweeper he worked at
domino's pizza got held up at gunpoint
like several times for real like
delivery yeah i'm like you were a chief
in the navy no one would have you're
pairing jet planes on an aircraft
carrier in taiwan and now you're working
at dominoes
don't you want to like aim higher not
that dominoes is bad but you you're
crazy
that's the air force he's the wrong yeah
military that's true
um so yeah it was confusing so he just
started doing like odd jobs and then he
started a business where he was advising
high school kids on college she never
went to college
and i was like this feels like not a
good idea but i don't want to say
anything because they're my parents i
guess they know um and then and then
they got to the flea markets
and i grew up a lot in flea markets okay
i gotta i'm gonna stop you there and
just so the whole time though dad and
mom are together i know she's leaving
and doing her thing but dad's there and
they're married not emotionally there
but yes they are married and living in
the same way and he tolerates this and
they screamed at each other all right
okay they did argue [ __ ] time okay
yeah
screamed like i would be at friends
houses and they the parents like my our
next-door neighbors would invite my
parents over for dinner because they had
a son around my age and i was like best
friends with him and uh they would be
having dinner and then i'm playing with
stephen and upstairs and then
my mom and dad just start fighting and
the other couple is like okay
you guys can go over your house and do
that and they didn't even like no one
else existed they were just screaming at
each other they didn't they didn't take
have the wherewithal to take a step back
and go i'm at someone's house for dinner
right no i'm not even in my own home
maybe i should zip it zip it nope yeah
none of that
yeah
yeah and then the flea markets came into
my life tell me about those
we would have to dig through my
neighbor's
and
trash
junking to for antiques to sell at a
flea market it was very embarrassing
because my mama called going junkies
putting that [ __ ] on yep they bought a
really shitty van that was moments away
from falling apart
uh we would take it around the
neighborhoods in the middle of the night
where you dig through people's trash
yeah but these are we found some good
[ __ ] honestly so i was like all right
well i believe people start some nice
things away i was here after the right
after the northridge quake in 94 when i
was going to college and um man people
in beverly hills throw some good [ __ ]
away just put it right out on the street
beverly hills yeah i want to do that
tonight that's what i'm saying they just
wait let's trash they put it beverly
hills don't leave it out anymore but
after the earthquake they were just like
get this broken [ __ ] or this [ __ ] out of
here it was a set these times you were
like god damn people were going all over
taking [ __ ]
damn they could have sold that for a lot
of money but now too i hear that it's
hard to run a u-haul so many people are
leaving but other people are renting
them around here because people just
want to get the [ __ ] out they're not
even selling their [ __ ] just throwing
their couches and stuff on the curb and
these people are going all over the
valley and snagging up all this stuff
that's great hey cool you'd be doing
that right now that's what i would have
i've been to the flea markets i have um
so they're special place especially in
virginia so the pasadena rose bowl does
it used to be probably still do it the
second sunday of every month they would
have a monster flea market in the
parking lot around the rose bowl
rose bowl seats a hundred thousand it's
it's massive yeah
so tables as far as the eye can be yeah
but it's been four or five times now
where i've gone and taken my [ __ ]
basically i'm having a yard sale at the
rose bowl right when i got there what i
didn't realize is like this guy next to
me got a sign all built
and like
right all day over here
over like these these
i'm
are
there like i gotta fight out a blanket
you know and [ __ ] like that but i stole
the vhs table
i sell the table i bring [ __ ] on and if
i don't i hit goodwill on the way out
donate and i'm gone yeah yeah we would
do that so we would we would take our so
when i got a couple years older like six
seven uh we would go and then she would
bid on junk piles tr go we would go to
auctions and bid on
junk from porter's house
and sell it or just decorate your home
no okay so well it ended up in our home
so what would happen is we would bid on
a junk pile truly it was like the size
of this room okay a pile maybe up to the
ceiling it was just me and my mom
we would go there and she would bid i'm
six
and then after that we have to sort
through it because not all the stuff is
good so we had to spend hours sorting
through it and we put it all in the van
and we took it from the van to the
to the living room and we were never
allowed to have people over because i
was like mom can my friends sleep over
and she's like no the living
everything's a mess like you couldn't
even see the floor of our home really at
one point yeah it's covered in [ __ ]
and i was like but you can we i don't
care i didn't care but my mom did and
i'm like well then why is there um like
can you clean it up then like i'm not
trying to be a bitcher
um
but uh i never voiced my needs ever i
never stood up to myself because i was
so scared of her and i was i felt bad
for her and i felt like i didn't exist
only she existed so i i didn't even at
the time i was like okay i guess i'll
just sleep over my friend's house like i
didn't you know fight back
um and yeah so um and then we would go
to bill's flea market in virginia beach
and we would take the van and she would
set up a table and she had severe
depression and she was on a lot of
medications she slept all the time so
she would price things
not everything put it on a table and we
would just sit there and then she would
go in the van and fall asleep and be in
a depression coma or a medication while
the sales go on while the people are
walking up
and i
at six
had to negotiate with these white trash
alcoholic toothless
probably molesters
probably on antiques and then i would
wake my mom i would go to wake my mom
she slept so deeply when she napped and
she snored so loud and i would have to
shake her i would have physically shake
and she would yell at me for waking her
up and i'm like i don't know what you
want me to do there's this guy here that
wants to buy this thing and he wants to
offer you
ten dollars and you put 12 to i'll and
so but i had a good attitude about it
because i was just like i gotta help my
mom she also told me um she was sore all
the time her shoulders and neck were
always sore and she would ask me to
massage them and i would i would massage
her shoulders and then one day she said
to me you know the longer you should
massage mommy's shoulders the longer
she'll live
and i was like you remember that your
life is in my hands literally i have the
power to keep you alive i need to you
know go that's heavy yep yep uh so a lot
of flea and then they went from flea
market to a toy store they bought a
store if they rented a storefront
what do you mean a storefront they
rented a store and a parking cent a
shopping center small thing yeah and
maybe they called it a toy connection
and it was toys from all decades that we
got and the junk places um they would
order some wholesale
and he was just like guys you don't okay
whatever and it's just for years our
house was covered in [ __ ] uh and my mom
was in and out of you know depression
and mental illness and
all this and then um
is it paying the bills and enough like i
think tell me about are you what are you
middle class lower we were lower middle
class we were we were
right
yeah yeah yeah we had a hat we had a
house yeah right not a great one we have
a little class i would say although my
parents always stressed about money
openly to us which was awful um
and i think this they were just
i
i'm starting to uncover a lot because i
ended up cutting my parents off i don't
speak to them anymore which is a huge
thing for me
uh but uh
they would allude to being stressed they
would like push their financial stress
onto us and they knew i was a sensitive
kid and i cared a lot and i was just
worried all the time about everything so
it was like they would give me things to
worry about and kind of keep me here
um but i think that he was a chief in
the navy my mom was on disability she
didn't work she couldn't she had
physical just some physical disabilities
you wouldn't know looking at her but um
she had a lot of learnt she had learning
disabilities uh she was always oh
how did your mom and dad meet
in florida
they're both from new jersey they're
both from the same town in new jersey
they met in florida my mom's 18. she was
escaping an abusive boyfriend uh her her
mother flew her down to florida to stay
with her aunt uh to escape this guy who
she thought was going to kill him and
she's on the beach with her girlfriend
she took her girlfriend and um
she was lying on the beach in florida
and my mom had driven my um her aunt's
car there it was a stick shift um
and
while she was on the beach she could
sleep on the beach you could also have
cars on the beach at that time uh a
giant truck ran backed into her while
she was asleep on the beach ran over her
arm and leg and ran into her neck but
because she was on the sand she sunk
down this freaked her out so badly she
didn't go to the hospital
she just went back to her aunt's house
and was just like shaking she should
have been like hurt it [ __ ] her up but
she was able to walk and stuff after the
next day with tire tracks on her hands
she was at a pool t uh pool hall and the
owner of the pool hall was like oh nancy
you're from new jersey right you meet ed
he's also from new jersey i think he's
from the same town and my dad was like
who why happened to you you look like
you got ran over by a truck and she's
like actually i did and then the rest is
is history they found out that they
found out that my mom's mom was my dad's
sunday school teacher they're they're
nine years apart they're nine years
apart they met in florida so there's a
cool and so she very quickly moved
in with him she just moved all her stuff
and moved in and then they had my
brother yeah so uh yeah it was looking
back at it i feel like i was pretty
codependent
love but
that word didn't even wasn't even in the
vernacular at that time so yep yeah uh
and so yeah the flea markets
um so much happened
um then my parents separated my mom took
me out to an ihop
um which was my favorite restaurant we
never like went we always went to
buffets because they were so cheap we
didn't go so when we shook me ihop i was
so excited but it was to tell me that
her and my dad were separating
and she i remember she was like you can
get whatever you want and i was like can
i get chocolate chip pancakes and she
was
right except for our marriage your
parents being together
um you can't get that um but even if we
were together we'd make your life hell
so tell either way
uh and she was bawling bawling
she let me order chocolate chip pancakes
and i was like what
cool
and then we ordered we were sitting
there and she was like i was about eight
okay
nine
um and then she starts crying and she's
like your father and i are separating do
you want to live with him or me you have
to pick one and i was like what and then
the waitress was like here's your
pancakes
it was
and i i still crave chocolate chip
pancakes to this day and i think it's
like my it's my cutting yeah
it's my cutting
it's my cutting yeah
yeah
um yeah
and so they separated for three years
and i moved to pennsylvania
um and i
okay so wait
you moved to pennsylvania with who with
my mom okay and dad stays in virginia
yep he stays there okay so that's a
little bit of difference yeah yeah how
many hours are we looking from where
she's going
because
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's about a seven
eight hour drive damn okay yeah so
significant um do you remember how your
dad feels about this yeah so the last
night my dad uh doesn't not comfortable
talking about emotions very yeah you
know military also very and we were
raised very militaristically in in some
respects um the last night at my dad's
house i didn't want to stay with him i
stayed at my best friend katie's house
uh and i remember feeling so guilty and
i called him the next morning because he
had left for work so i wasn't gonna see
him like before like before i got picked
up to go to pennsylvania and that was
the only time i've ever heard him cry
and i was like
so yeah
this is the honeydew with ryan sickler
yeah so that was the only time i've ever
heard and he was bawling like a baby
like me and you're about to make me cry
thinking of my daughter leaving good
lord and i was like oh i i thought he
was crying because i i thought he was
crying because i didn't spend that last
night with him
because i didn't understand
and so i felt guilty about that
for so long i felt guilty about
everything but uh that one that one ate
me up for a while
lived with my
mom uh we cleaned houses for a living we
lived in like a condo we went from this
like beautiful house to a to a
two-bedroom condo did your brother go as
well no he stayed with my he was in
college at that point so he just went to
college richmond uh and then my mom and
i cleaned houses um while uh
and
um she we cleaned houses to pay for my
braces and she reminded me of that uh
every day
um that she bent over backwards to pay
for my braces meanwhile like
too depressed to pick me up from play
practice i was always the last kid every
time always the last kid to get picked
up because she was slept all the time um
and so it would just be me and uh the
[ __ ] security guard at the school we
like bonded hardcore um every every
[ __ ] thing extracurricular activity i
did not get picked up like she had to
wait um hours and then she got mad at me
i'm like i don't know what you want here
lady listen if you're out there looking
for a home the truth is that house
prices are only going to continue to
skyrocket the time to start planning is
now and i recommend that everyone listen
to the how to buy a home podcast it's an
incredible free resource with everything
you need to know to navigate this
process host david cedoni is an industry
expert with years of experience who
actually cares about first-time home
buyers just like you he answers
questions like when is the best time to
start how do i even start will a
mortgage be more than my current monthly
rent probably not the good news is he
just released an emergency episode of
how to buy a home all about the bidding
wars of 2022 with insider tips and
tricks to win
david has helped make buying a home a
reality for so many people and i know
the reason you keep hearing david come
back here is because you guys are
listening and using his services and
some of you have already bought your
first home you guys are commenting on
youtube you're throwing it up on the
social so i know it's working so if
you're interested i'm telling you right
now he can help you no matter what stage
you're in and even connect you with the
great realtor in your area all right
listen to the how to buy a home podcast
today david can help find how to buy a
home wherever you listen to podcasts if
you have multiple credit card balances
each month and are only paying the
minimums like i did for years barely
making a dent in your credit card debt
it can be discouraging upstart can help
you pay off your existing debt quickly
so you can feel like you're finally
getting ahead whether it's paying off
your credit cards or consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
with a clear payoff date upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
so rather than looking at your credit
score alone upstart's model considers
other factors like your income
employment and other information
provided in your loan application to
fine you a smarter rate for your loan
and you can check your rate without
impacting your credit score in just five
minutes for loans between a thousand all
the way up to fifty thousand dollars you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to
upstart.com honeydew you guys know i'm a
big believer in mental health i think
that people are out there working out
their bodies and not their minds enough
and this is a mental health show so
learning to manage daily stress and
anxious thoughts is something we all
want but many of us don't even know
where to begin and new mood is here to
guide you to mental wellness and give
you the tools you need to tackle stress
so you'll feel empowered to take on
whatever life throws at you i already
started doing therapy again i went back
to therapy yesterday as a matter of fact
and i just think it's a great thing for
everyone all right
and new mood has a team of dedicated
coaches so you have a support system
helping you my favorite thing about it
is that it's literally a step-by-step
guide to help you manage your mental
wellness and you can do it at your own
pace you can arm yourself with knowledge
and the skills for happiness and they'll
help you better understand your personal
relationship with stress and anxious
thoughts so you can take control build
resilience and develop coping mechanisms
that actually work all you need is 10
minutes a day and it's an app so it's
there for you anytime anywhere worry
less and feel happier sign up for your
trial at noom.com
honeydew that's n o o m
dot com slash honeydew start your trial
today now let's get back to the do so
moving on to the suicide attempt
my parents get back together they do
yeah
my dad sends her books of poetry
that he's writing no
thank god
it's a big jump for a guy that
doesn't even address feelings yeah send
her books of poetry
i'm like whoa it comes up to visit very
gradually they come up and so we end up
three years i was in pennsylvania three
years with just my mom
and how often are you seeing your dad in
that time once or twice a year okay
and but he yeah and uh they got back
together we bought a house in
pennsylvania okay so he moved up there
yeah yeah high school starts
at first they weren't fighting because
they were separated for so long and then
they started back up again
and
uh but i i didn't i don't know i didn't
really i was a good kid in high school i
was very scared to break the rules
because i was scared of being a bad
daughter like that was that was like my
main concern
and
so
the night before i moved away to college
i was going to penn state main campus
i was living with a girl i was really
close friends with i was so excited this
was my first experience with like
autonomy really and and because my my
parents were so or my mom
mainly
was so concerned with my safety at all
times even though i wasn't doing
high-risk activities she was always
worried about me if a friend that i had
she heard a friend curse she would get
so mad like why are you friends with
this person they're bad they're bad
they're a bad person
she would just pressure me and criticize
me all the goddamn time um and so and it
was sometimes it would come in spurts
just out of nowhere and so this last day
before i moved away to college she was
taking me shopping for my dorm room and
i was over the moon excited
we were at walmart getting a microwave
and she was just in the sourest mood but
i was so
excited that i was like you can't
nothing you could do can ruin this for
me um and she started yelling at me at a
walmart and i was i was confused as to
why she would yell at me all the time
for like things that i didn't
necessarily do
and so
she starts yelling at me that i'm
selfish or something and she leaves me
in the walmart
she just leaves
and i had to call my dad to pick me up
that was the second time that like drove
away yep
she was like i can't take you christina
you're ungrateful you're blah blah blah
yeah she is she's like i'm leaving your
father can come pick you up and i was
like
all right cool i still gotta buy this
microwave because i told liz i'd buy the
microwave so like we got you know and uh
that was the second time that happened
the first time that happened
i was 16 out of the restaurant with my
mom my
my dad's mom my grandmother who had a
stroke so she had the mentality of a
five-year-old
she would pick she would take her
dentures out and just lick them all the
time
yeah she would pick things off of
people's plates as she walked through a
restaurant she would go what i wanted it
i'm like you can't do that she was a
[ __ ] um and uh sorry and um
and it was me my mom my grandmother who
had a stroke and my brother's girlfriend
and and in that when i was 16 years old
and uh and
very vividly i remember my mom bringing
up a friend's daughter who moved to new
york city and she was alluding that she
was having sex she was eluding that this
she was being [ __ ] and my mom turned
to me i had a boyfriend at the time my
very first boyfriend that i was madly in
love with he was cheating on me the
whole time but i didn't know yet i lost
my virginity to him and before this
conversation or after before okay and
uh yeah so that's where i was at she was
telling me about her friend and his
daughter moved to new york city and was
being a [ __ ] and she was like you
wouldn't you haven't done any of that
stuff right christina and i i would
never lie to my mom because i always
told her the truth which was a mistake
and i was like well
i have actually she got up
like do one of these
marched out of the restaurant and i was
like and it was me my grandmother and my
brother's girlfriend and i was like i
guess we gotta call my dad
the last thing i wanted was my mom mad
at me
and she was
[Music]
and i remember it was snowy that night
it was like snowy and then when we
eventually got home my grandmother while
we were walking out of the restaurant
kept taking things off of people's
plates
you can't do that grandma she's like
don't yell at me like i just want to get
out of this restaurant
and then we were when we got home my mom
was already home and my grandma fell on
the sidewalk she fell slipped on ice
because i couldn't [ __ ] carry her she
was gigantic and then my bro and then i
fell and she starts crying she's like
nobody loves me like she acted like a
kid this woman
it was just it was awful my mom didn't
talk to me for weeks
so fast forward the night before i moved
away to college
we're in walmart part two
but there was she did you know it wasn't
because i was a [ __ ] it was just because
uh i don't who knows at this point um
she got mad at me left walmart i had to
call my dad and at that point i was like
i've had it with that
that was my big
[ __ ] you uh um kind of
expression and i was mad i was telling
my dad i'm like why does she do this and
she my dad was always like
she's your mom like don't don't worry
about it like just make sure she's okay
like my dad fed this whole narrative of
like
you let your mom do what she's gonna do
she's sick it's fine um without ever
asking us how does this make you feel um
and so
my dad picked me up from the walmart
and we pulled into our house
because i still had a pack all my stuff
for to move away to college next day and
half of it was packed half of it wasn't
as we pull up my mom is walking down the
street of our neighborhood with a with a
with a giant beer glass filled with
vodka
and we i get out of the car and i'm like
mom
she's like don't talk to me and i was
like okay
all right whatever in my head i was like
whatever [ __ ] okay um and it was weird
it was off color of her because she
doesn't usually drink she didn't drink a
lot and uh she walked away and i was
like whatever and then so i'm packing
i'm loading things in the van i'm still
like nothing's gonna ruin this i'm so
excited
and
hours go by and it's like 1am and she's
not back and we're like that's
that's weird right and i was like dad we
should should we call the cops he's like
i think so and i was like okay let's
call the cops so we called the cops uh
um my dad talked to him
and then two of them rolls by and we're
like asses
this is weird like where is she and she
she had a um you know she had a huge
beverage alcoholic beverage on her so
i'm like is she drunk passed out
somewhere i don't i don't know um this
had never happened before and so we
finally a phone we get a phone call and
it's a family friend
and
it's this guy and he was like hey um i
have your mother on the other line i'm
gonna i'm gonna
connect all the calls don't say anything
because if she knows you're on the other
line she's gonna hang up
based off of the conversation i've had
with her so far we're like okay so my
dad's on the my dad has the phone
upstairs on the phone you know the
landline remember when you could do that
yeah yeah two people on the same call um
on one side um and then she start so
that he patches us all through and she
is
obliterated i've never seen her drunk
and um
and then
uh she mentioned she's at the train
tracks by her house and i was like oh
that's okay i'm thinking of like an
old-timey cartoon of like some old
[ __ ] drunk with a sack um sitting by
the train tracks and i was like that's
weird i was like and i was in my head
i'm like well come home and uh and then
she starts talking about how um she
needs to leave the earth
she she talked about killing herself and
then i'm like mom mom mom whoa whoa
hello what hi it's me it's christina and
she's like christina i'm like yes hi mom
like dude please don't do where are you
where like where are you and um and i
heard the train
oh [ __ ] and then she's like
she's like you you don't need me anymore
you have your father you don't you know
i'm just a burden in your life and i was
like no you're not mom you're not like i
need please don't jump and she's she i
forget what she was saying she was like
being very
nonsensical but that she got out and i
heard the train
and i thought she died like i thought i
just heard her die and so i screamed and
i threw the phone and i knew i knew
where she was
uh because i knew the pathway to get to
the tracks there was only a couple so i
ran my dad called 9-1-1 and i was like
i'm about to see my mom like her guts
everywhere i don't know
she slipped and hit her head she tried
to jump and she really did try though
yeah she was on the rocks
half of the track was like a cliff
almost and then half of it was like
yardage you know with grass uh she had
so i found her uh
knocked out she was bleeding from her
head and there was the ambulance was
already there thank god thank god i
wasn't the one who um
arrived at the scene first
but i ran i booked it jesus and i sat
and i sat in the back of the ambulance
holding her hand
and and she was just telling me how she
doesn't want to be alive she wants to
die all this stuff and then uh went to
the hospital i sat with her they patched
her up she didn't have an injury or
anything there was no head injury thank
god which was a miracle
and then the next day i moved to penn
state
lyons here we go
[Applause]
i feel like god held out the paterno
[ __ ] until after i left penn state so i
could have some [ __ ] fun
so i can enjoy the penn state college
campus life
i feel like sandusky
that was there like we need to pause
this reveal sorry all the people are
gonna get molested for it uh because
christina needs to have some fun
in her life
man yeah it's day one at college
and didn't tell i didn't tell anybody
i didn't tell anybody what happened
because i'm now i'm a [ __ ] open book
i'll [ __ ] tell a stranger but your
email we bullet pointed up there uh has
an s next to suicide attempts yeah yeah
yeah that's the first that was uh no
there was there was one previous that i
wasn't really involved in there was one
that i found out way later um when she
was living in a car uh there was that
was one and then there's probably more
that i don't know of but um
and then uh the second year of college
my second year of college i wanted
always wanted to be on saturday night
live that was my dream and so at penn
state it was
one of the best years ever i loved that
year i love penn state
and uh but i was like i really want to
be an snl i got to go to i got to move
to new york i transfer schools because i
can intern at snl and that is a surefire
way for them to know who i am without me
having to you know figure out how do i
get on the cast that's that there's a
way there's an in so i moved to new york
and my mom was so worried about me
new york's so dangerous there's so much
crying there's someone oh my god i'm so
scared for you she wanted to move me in
with my dad and i was like last time
that didn't really go well
so i'm gonna say probably not the best
idea and she insisted and my dad was
like just let her just i'm like okay
fine
and they moved me in
and
we're in my little dorm room and it's
the dorm room for all only transfer
students so with all transfer kids and i
was so nervous new york's terrifying um
and i was very i was very scared but i
was like you just gotta [ __ ] suck it
up and do it you gotta get over it and
um my parents moved me in my mom started
to get a sour mood she started to pick a
fight with my dad started screaming at
my dad in the dorm room hallway in front
of everybody
and my dad was just kind of like
and she goes you know what ed we're fine
i'll [ __ ] walk back to fill a [ __ ]
delphia
and she just walks out of my dorm room
and walks away and i was like are you
and that's when i was like
all right fool me once shame on me or
but fool me twice you're a [ __ ] i don't
want to talk to you anymore um and so i
that was the first moment where i really
got mad at her it was an adult at this
point yeah
yeah yeah yeah
uh and so and then she was rambling
about on my jump in front of a bus and i
was like oh my god and i honestly at
that point i was like try not to slip on
the curb
exactly
but it's this weird dichotomy man when
you have a mentally ill parent
you
you feel so guilty and bad saying
anything bad about them like you feel
like you have to protect their
reputation but really you're protecting
yourself that's right from their
reputation that's right so it's wild
it's wild what it does to you
i'm learning in uh this emdr therapy my
second round i say it right yeah
sometimes i mess up and say edm yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but it's not
your relationship to the person or the
thing it's your relationship to the
relationship the memory thing that's
right that's exactly it it's not like
you're still mad at somebody from 20
years ago well it's not not today it's
your relation your
yes yeah relationship to the memory yeah
yeah
uh and i know this is not a list but i
feel like i can replace one because this
is a really interesting one
i said sell it sell it uh my mom was
adopted
okay uh when she was and she uh by a
lovely couple um
when she was about three she had
siblings
yeah yeah
my not her biological her biological mom
killed herself uh because she tried to
kill all the kids she had a lot of
siblings whoa
um she killed herself while the kids
were like in the house and so the state
took my mom and siblings and they got
adopted uh
and so because of that we didn't know
much about her health history uh and
some of the relatives were they were
mostly passed away and so i got my mom i
do i do a bit about this in the special
full disclosure but the story is crazy
i got my mom 23 of me kit for christmas
one year her birthday's on christmas
christmas was always a big deal in our
house and um
i got her 23andme kid i thought
because i was really excited i'm like oh
we can actually get some
actual information about your background
and she
she just didn't seem to care which i
thought was weird because usually she's
like pretends to care even if she
doesn't with a present i give her
because oh my god thank you she always
puts on a show um she didn't put on a
show with that one and i was like that's
strange and so
um it made me like she kind of tossed it
to the side so i was like well i'll just
do the kit you don't have to do it i'll
do it i don't care because she seemed so
hesitant and uh and i did it i did the
kit and i um got the results back and i
learned uh it said you were 51 ashkenazi
jewish and i was like oh [ __ ]
i was like mom you're jewish like cause
dad my dad was um english and german and
something uh but not jewish i was like
obviously dad's not jewish so you're
jewish moms that means i'm really jewish
if the mom's jewish and she was like and
i remember she was like oh cool i'm like
do you hate jews what what's going on
and um
i thought it was cool and so uh there's
a couple health things that i learned
and
and then uh you download the 21 3m app
and then a
couple months into having the app
i started getting messages from people
saying that they were my half sibling
and i was like
so what why because now your information
is in the system and those people can
see so dna matches so you can you can
you can opt in to say if there's anybody
that fits your dna has a dna match with
you do you want them to be able to
contact you and vice versa on the app
and i was like yeah because if we find
um
a relative of my mom's i guess
um that would be great and that's like a
really surefire way your dna just gets
compared with all these other d so it's
like really efficient and so i started
getting these messages from dna
relatives and i was like oh cool
but they said that one of the one woman
was like oh we're half siblings um
uh we have the same dad but i was raised
by him so if you have any like questions
about his health history and stuff let
me know because i you know grew up with
him and i was like what
and i was like that i was like oh okay
that's that's cool i don't really know
what you're talking about and i was
texting my brother about it i was like
that's so weird do you think like um
because my dad is a brother so i'm like
do you think my our uncle donated sperm
and maybe because it's my dad's brother
that like something like that because
the other message was like oh are you a
sperm donor baby too um we're half
siblings like that's so cool and i was
like what the [ __ ] is happening i was
getting all these messages
and i was very confused so i called my
mom and i was you know comics when
something weird potentially happens to
you you post it but you make a joke
about it right so i was i was putting
these screenshots on my instagram
stories of like oh i think i'm about to
find out my family's not my family
and um
and i was texting with my brother and i
was like what the [ __ ] is this
and i was like i'm gonna call my mom but
i filmed it i have a v i felt i took my
ipad out and i filmed it because i was
like i'm about to find out that um i'm
the mailman's kid which my brother
coincidentally had been saying to me my
whole life because i don't look like
anybody in my family he had he always
said that but he was just we joked
around with each other like we teased
each other like siblings so i didn't
think anything of it
and uh i called my mom up and i was like
hey mom they're um
so that 23 me kit that i got i'm getting
all these messages from people saying
that they're my half sibling and that
that i was a sperm like there was a
sperm donor that's
i was like dad's my dad's my biological
father right and she was like
oh
actually
he's not what i did not expect you to
say that [ __ ]
he's not
um
i never thought i would ever be telling
you this i never thought this would get
out uh we've
your dad had testicular cancer i really
wanted a second kid i mean she's
obviously crying when she's saying this
you know through the tears in the
um
so please imagine that uh we wanted a
second kid i wanted one so badly and uh
his sperm wasn't good because of the
cancer and so i i asked him you know can
we get a donor and he goes only if she
never know only if the baby never knows
and she goes okay sure i don't care
and
my mom was like i've tried to talk to
your dad about it a couple times and he
very vehemently said nope we're not
telling her and then you got me that 23
of me kit and i was like oh she gone now
and now you know and i was like
wow
okay
i'm gonna go
but i'll talk to you later and she was
like don't tell your brother don't tell
anybody
um
and she like wanted me to keep it this
big secret she's like don't tell your
dad yet i'll tell your dad
she's crying and crying oh my god
okay and that
that took me that took three years to
sink in i i mean
i couldn't i don't know if that would
ever [ __ ] sink in you live your whole
life a certain way only to find out not
that you have these other siblings
because of a past relationship that your
dad might have had or a little oops from
a side chick or even mom
what these cars at virginia beach right
you know nothing nothing no it's that
your dad isn't your dad yeah but with
the logically but with the life i'd
lived up until that point i was [ __ ]
negotiating with white trash toothless
[ __ ] over [ __ ] i got from the trash
while my mom was in a depression coma in
the van i'm like this fits with how my
life has been going
do you well now i have a million
questions so do you know who the man is
your biological father he he ended up
taking his own life he doesn't holy [ __ ]
are you kidding me so suicide even on
that [ __ ] thing too yeah he was a
doctor yeah uh uh but it was i don't i
don't know that he i don't know that he
had the clinical depression um he seemed
like a really sweet guy there's a lot of
articles about him that i found that
like really i'm like wow this guy seems
like a really kind person he was a
doctor in philadelphia so real quick is
your brother's father he's a whole one
he's that is his biological death yeah
okay so that's real yeah yeah that's
real how many siblings have you found
that you have to about 19. no
yeah 90
donated my blood plasma every weekend
because it was 45 bucks cash and i was
like gonna take this cash i'm gonna go
uh get a freshman or get a sophomore to
buy me beer um that was my spending
money was donating plasma
so
if all you had to do was jerk off into a
tube i'd do that all damn day well i
tried to do that when i was in college
as well but they told me that you're
only allowed to you're supposed to only
be allowed to do two
um
donations in a certain mile radius
because that's a nice rule although it's
not
probable it is possible that those two
siblings could especially if they stay
in the area could meet yeah what if they
[ __ ] right unbeknown to them they're
[ __ ]
yeah they're having inbred babies yeah
yeah but we had a we had a girl come on
the patreon who had just gone through
this too and found out that her father
was he was going he went every week for
i think she said 10 years and i said
that could be 520 siblings and since
that show she had connected with like
probably have you have you said what 19
19. and i met the bo the one that was
raised by him i met with karen at
rupaul's drag con i was dressed as a
drag queen i met her and her wife and
her son and i was like hi
nice to meet you i'm like in drag
hi
this is weird huh
i don't really look like you
i don't look like the dad i don't look
like her i'm like i don't look like
anybody
this is how you do with ryan's
okay
all right so
when do you have the conversation with
your dad
a couple months after that
months you waited that long my mom made
me because she hadn't told him yet she
yeah she just didn't know she didn't
want to she didn't [ __ ] why didn't you
just say [ __ ] everyone now i want this
conversation you're still trying to be a
good daughter even then
all right so mom tells dad first heads
up your daughter knows what's well
yep the girl you've been telling your
adult is your daughter yeah she's my dad
yeah i want to tell you he loved me like
i was his kids earlier you mentioned
cutting
your parents off so i wasn't sure if you
did feel that way but this is the man
who's raised this is your dad i
respected him more i honestly but but
that's but that's also it's how i react
to things so i
i don't even consider any negative
aspect of of
or or or a way i would be i'm
disrespected if i'm being i don't
consider how i'm being treated in any
situation uh historically and so uh in
this situation because i was always like
mom mom mom you you first
when we had this guy when my mom talked
to me i'm like are you okay this must be
hard for you wow you kept the secret
from me for a while that's a lot of
stress and like i was just concerned
with her i didn't even think uh i've
been [ __ ] putting the wrong health
history on my medical forms for my whole
life yeah i was busy
getting older for sure and it's only
it's there's nothing to be ashamed about
but they're
the only shame is that it was a secret
don't keep the [ __ ] seat that's a
huge secret that you kept for me that
was that's how many years when did you
33.
oh no i found out i was 31. i found out
god
yeah
man you don't see that [ __ ] coming do
you
what a day but when it did i was like
yeah that makes sense not surprised yeah
because just weird [ __ ] happens to me
all the time
of a similar so how did your dad take it
was he emotional was he like apologetic
or was he defiant how was he
i
knew that he's not and he it's hard to
talk to him about things about seriously
you only heard him cry once yeah i'm
curious if this is the second time wow
really no but i but i was comforting him
so i was like hey and i meant i really
didn't mean this part but i was like you
know i really
i respect your decision i understand why
you didn't want to tell me and i really
appreciate you raised me as if i was
biologically yours um
yeah
so i was like thank you for having me
okay good night like that was that was a
conversation um but yeah that was a wild
one that was uh
that's a wild one but so the cutting off
part finally comes where um basically my
whole life every boyfriend i've ever had
and every close friend i've ever had has
always remarked on how odd of a
relationship i have with my parents i'll
drop anything if they call i drop
whatever i'm doing to to answer the
phone
um they would have weird rules on me
that i didn't understand at the time i
should have been like hey i'm a grown-up
and i'm not doing that with all the
respect boundaries for myself too i
never set a boundary with them there's
no boundaries um and
uh every friend i've ever had was like
your parents
are weird to you and i was like no
they're not and i sometimes i would get
offended when a friend would say that
because i'm like don't you say anything
bad about my parents like i would
protect them like i was a knight and
they were the king and queen
and um
and then i read a book called you're not
crazy it's your mother
and i learned about narcissistic
personality disorder
and i
i download the audiobook of this
and
i read it when i was on the road i was
doing a weekend solo a solo weekend by
myself on the road and i downloaded it
and i listened to all eight hours i
didn't sleep because it was it was it it
it described things that i was like
oh that is [ __ ] up okay the suicide
attempts
you know
she had a lot of them she didn't do it
she wasn't really good at it she didn't
that made me think that wasn't the goal
the timing of her suicide attempts was
always when i was about to go off into
the world and i was like
keep you here you are a narcissist yeah
that is what everything revolves around
you
every and you have me right
you might as well have me on a [ __ ]
leash
everything is surrounding you your
emotions are paramount whatever i'm
going through doesn't [ __ ] matter
it's how you're feeling or how i make
you feel that's the only thing that
matters and they [ __ ] fed into that
[ __ ] there's this thing that i learned
called triangulation where you pit
you're pitted against another family
member whether it's a sibling or a
parent or whatever
uh everything that this book described
were basically a list of all the
inappropriate emotionally manipulative
abusive things my parents have done both
of them
uh and when we started making money uh
corn and i uh like the podcast got
really successful and we got i remember
like the first big deposit from the comp
like that went into my bank account i
like i still have the atm receipt
because i was like i just felt like a
billionaire um because we credit i was
so broke in new york for for most of our
time there uh up until that point uh the
first big check i got
my parents were like oh we're gonna move
to florida because it's cheap or
whatever and they're like or we can move
to new jersey if you'd be interested in
buying a house with us and i was like
okay i got all that money wired it right
to my dad the next day and i was like oh
all of it damn it all of it all that i
didn't pay taxes on that six figures i
had to pay taxes on that i gave all of
it to them and then i had if i was i'm
like oh my god after i read this book
and i learned they train you to bow down
to them essentially whether they're
doing it consciously or subconsciously
it in my opinion it doesn't [ __ ]
matter uh
but
boy oh boy have i gotten tricked my
whole life what did they do with that
money uh we bought the house we have a
house it is
so we got an llc we split that so the
house is 50 mine so it's an asset so it
wasn't i didn't like you know just give
it to him uh thank god but what made
what was the line where you cut them off
and was it a separate thing or were you
on like all right
yeah uh my mom one day we were out on
the porch on the beach house um she came
out with her laptop and she was telling
me how black lives matter uh you don't
know where the money is going because i
had been marching it was quarantine uh
but i'd been marching and she was so
worried and so concerned and she was
like this you can't trust black lives
matter i'm like yes i can i can't trust
you [ __ ] i didn't say that but uh
but i wanted to at least i thought it i
was like ooh naughty
um
but i and i remember i i i felt the
anger and the rage well up in me like i
always had and instead of i either would
suppress it or i would scream at them
and they would go oh
how can you if when i would get mad at
them for very just reasons they would go
are you okay what what's wrong with you
oh my god i'm worried about you are you
addicted to drugs christina and i'm like
i'm not oh my god like they made me so
crazy so that night she came out of the
porch i've just [ __ ] left i didn't
even say anything they pulled him off
away and i'm like yeah
[ __ ] you how do you think about that i'm
like oh she's not mad at me like this
and um and then um this is still before
i read that book um
uh quarantine was happening uh mom got
fox news kidnapped both my parents uh
they allowed it but um you know i kind
of lost them to facebook and fox news
and um
there was a moment where my mom kept
emailing me and texting me and i stopped
responding which was unlike out of
character for me and so she would get
very angry with me and then she was like
i think you're addicted to drugs and
your happiness is fake and then i'm like
you're telling me how i'm doing
instead of asking how are you doing you
don't care about me i'm like also you
don't really [ __ ] like me that much
you don't you don't you're not nice to
me you're not nice to me you criticize
me everything i do is wrong
why do you why i don't want to hang out
i never i don't really want to see you
again and so i started pulling away from
her without like really drawing a hard
line in the sand yet
um and she was so up she was so
devastated that i was um i was that new
york city was being uh filled with
criminals with the pandemic and that i
was addicted so well god knows what drug
and and i i wasn't getting my work done
she's just making all the [ __ ] up and um
and she's like i need to i want to come
down and talk to you and i was like no
you're not doing that we're not doing
that um four days later
nine a.m
i'm in bed
and my buzzer rings
and i was like what and then i look up
at my phone and i have eight missed
calls and i'm like
okay
my mom's at my [ __ ] apartment she
drove to new york city
she's at my [ __ ] apartment buzzing
the buzzer
and it's the buzzer i lived in at the
time the building was kind of wonky and
the buzzer was extremely loud very
drying i hated when people buzzed
um
she's buzzing and i lo i finally lost my
mind finally i was screaming i was
throwing [ __ ] i was like i'm gonna i
called my brother call my therapist call
i called my dad and i was like what the
[ __ ] i told her not to come and i told
you to tell her not to come
and she came and she goes he goes well
go out there and talk to her i'm like
no
what no are you all right then what the
hell you talking about yeah seriously
and then i go wait
can i block them on my phone is that
legal like that's how that's how
that's how
munchauseny it had gotten i just asked
my therapist yesterday is that wrong
i'm having a trouble with the fact that
they're blood yeah is it wrong she's
like it's not wrong no you're not wrong
and i'm like i need to make better
boundaries from you yeah yeah yeah
because you'll go insane
uh and i blocked them i didn't let her
in dude i didn't let her inside i didn't
let her in my build it was pouring rain
she has tremors so she's smart she's
like shakes a lot so she's outside in
the cold it's raining and she's like let
me in and i'm like
no and i and i pulled up draw the
curtain i blocked them and i was like i
don't know how you're going to get home
because i was always so worried about
them i'll get home and i was like nope
we're done [ __ ] yeah good for you yeah
and then i cried cried cried for two
years
years
i don't i hate to cut it here but you
gotta get the hell out of here you
really do
yeah
yeah
yeah two years
go ahead and get another one girl yeah
yeah i just wanna make sure for adam
corolla i'm not mascara tears because
he's gonna go oh all right real quick
you have to go yeah
advice you would give to your 16 year
old self especially after this [ __ ]
you're not crazy it's your mother
that's what i would have given yeah
boundaries too i really feel like i
would say that to my own self and that's
one i hadn't thought of before yeah you
need boundaries for yourself yeah
this has been awesome thank you so much
thank you um will you please promote
everything one more time yeah our
special day is out on youtube uh it's a
debut comedy special of myself and
cornfisher youtube.com guys we [ __ ]
without the you and [ __ ] uh i'm at
christina hutch on all platforms um i'm
gonna be in uh baltimore maryland london
uh ireland and miami christina
hutchinson.com all right thank you so
much as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you